- All of us have ancestors
who were on the planet much
long- so before we were, and
I feel like they prayed for
this moment, I feel like
there were so many people who
wanted it, somehow it fell on
me, I don't know why. I got
this opportunity, and I have
to do everything I can to be
a good steward over-
- It fell on you because
you know what to do with it.
- I appreciate that, and the
reason I feel that that is
right is because all of those
other people who came before
me taught me, right?
(Kelly) I see.
- So, so they poured into
me, so that's what's- that's
what's exciting for me, for sure.
- Your story is so powerful,
like I didn't even- I was
reading all about you last
night, and I found out way more
that I didn't know, and what
does it feel like coming from
where, you know, the cards that
were handed to you in life,
and then ending up on the wa-
you know, getting on the Walk
of Fame a star, that's insane.
- Yeah, it feels like great
faith, right? Great faith.
(Kelly)- Yeah.
- And a lot of work, and it
took a lot of prayer and my
mother, who is an amazing
woman, I mean, she dealt with
all kinds of horrible things.
I don't wanna bring the mood
down in here but, just abuse
and- and things like that.
(stammers) I- I did as well,
in- in the house in New Orleans
at the hand of my father,
but the thing about it is, my
mother took me to church, she
taught me about faith. So I
always felt like I had
somewhere to go in dark times.
- I could always-
- Yeah
- pray, I could always believe. A lot of
people are getting away from
that, but I'm telling you
If you're not - if you
don't have - teach your kids
something to help them,
their- they'll turn to drugs,
they'll turn to all kinds
of things, so for me I'm so
grateful my mother taught
me about God and faith and
believing and holding on,
because I wouldn't be here.
(Kelly) - I wouldn't be here. Yeah.
- I wouldn't be here, I wouldn't be here.
- No.
That's my thing, like,
with belief and everything, I think
we focus so much in the news on the
negativity of this world and
on humanity, and that's what
I wanna do with this show- and
I feel like that's what you
do through all your projects,
you really inspire people and
motivate people to be better
humans and there's always a
positive message, that is like- the goal.
- Yeah
- That is my goal.
- Yeah. And- and you are,
cause I feel the light here, so
it's good.
- I love you. I love your whole vibe.